bien souvent en regardant en arrière on
se demande le jeu en valait-il la
chandelle
les récentes découvertes valait-elle
tant d'efforts incalculables et tout ce
qui a été sacrifié au nom de la victoire
vous recevez annuler immédiatement
l'atterrissage c'est un an
ce qui nous a menés à la victoire la
soif de connaissance ou l'insatiable
vanité
aujourd'hui à 17h30 heure locale un
cataclysme a eu lieu à la surface de
mars
est ce que vous réalisez ce qui s'est
passé on ignore combien de temps il lui
reste encore à vivre désormais mars est
devenu une destination pour satisfaire
notre curiosité
[Musique]
le seul moyen de se protéger de cette
vérité
ces deux éliminés